donc
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
étranger
c'est Leslie c'est une boule de soleil
salut je suis Leslie et je suis le je n'ai
jamais vu Leslie de mauvaise humeur tu
dois avoir une attitude positive donc si tu
as un handicap  anxiété comme moi
leslie a quelques conseils sur la façon de rester
sans stress
conseil numéro un si votre vie vous semble désordonnée
mettez une tenue qui vous fait vous sentir
sexy
et si je me sens dépassée reine des soins personnels
respire et offre-toi une
glace je suis  stressé au travail parce que
mon patron est un fluage il fait des
commentaires inappropriés sur mon corps
rappelez-vous toujours que la politesse est la clé
alors dites-lui poliment de se faire [ __ ] s'il vous plaît je
vous souhaite le meilleur pour vous
je m'en fous
tellement de pouvoir pour ton diplôme j'aime mes
fans
et je te verrai très bientôt bonne
année aussi
tu es le meilleur n'oublie pas que
tu